All right.
Thanks for coming folks.
I'm really pleased to be here.
Um,
so I'm going to give you a,
a whistle stop tour of a lot of the themes and stories that are in the book.
Um,
and this will go on for about half an hour and then we can have some questions
later.
Okay.
So I'm going to start by taking it back in time to 1675 to 350 years ago and to
Delft air town in the Netherlands where a man named Anthony Van Leuven hoke is
about to change the world.
Uh,
this man is not a scholar.
He has no scientific training at all,
but he does have two qualities,
are incredibly important.
He has an insatiable curiosity about the world around him and he has the world's
most powerful microscopes.
He makes them himself.
He grinds these impossibly perfect spherical lenses.
Um,
and he sandwiches them between two brass plates to create this object that looks
a little bit like a glorified door hinge,
but it does in fact magnify objects 10 times better than anything else that
exist at the time.
And 11 hope turns them on to everything he can find at the time onto bits of
animals and bitter plants onto water that he,
that has collected in an urn outside his house into water from canals and lakes
in Delft and everywhere he looks,
he sees tiny little organisms,
microscopic creatures that none till then no one knew existed.
He was the first person in all of history to see,
um,
to,
to see bacteria with his own eyes and to know that they exist.
And that must've been a truly momentous point of time,
um,
in,
in science,
in our,
the history of the world to know that these creatures that are everywhere we're
actually around.
He realizes that there are more organisms living in a drop of water or in the
dental plaque that collects in his teeth.
Then there are people in the entirety of the Netherlands.
Now,
was he disgusted by this?
Was He revolted by it?
Actually,
no,
he was really excited to learn that his body was full of all these other living
things.
The idea that microbes are synonymous with disease and dirt is actually a more
recent one.
Um,
it came a few centuries after live hope when scientists discovered in very quick
succession that many of the most infamous plagues of humanity,
things like actual plague,
leprosy,
gonorrhea,
syphilis,
cholera,
tuberculosis,
all of these diseases were caused by bacteria.
And so they forever became known as germs.
They became costs as villains,
as antagonists,
that we needed to destroy less.
They destroy us first.
Well,
at this point of view is deeply wrong.
It's unfair because only a few hundred kinds of microbes are known to cause
disease.
The vast majority are either benign or beneficial to us,
and in fact,
they are the lords of the planet.
They have been around for much longer than we have and they run the show.
So for we consider the length of this desk to be representative of the entire
history of the planet.
So the earth was created here and that we are now here.
Then humans evolved here.
Uh,
the dinosaurs ruled around here all the multicellular life that,
you know,
the animals and plants and so on revolved around here and microbes,
the first living things,
bacteria evolved to here.
So for the vast majority of life on earth,
it was entirely microscopic.
You were not as being able to see it with your naked eyes,
which would have been fine because eyes only evolved here.
Okay?
So we are all just the icing on this grand microbial cake.
Um,
animals evolved in a world that was already full of and dominated by microbes
and we came to live with them.
We evolved to exploit them and we evolved to crucially depend upon them.
Uh,
every human today,
all of us contain around 39 trillion microbial cells in our bodies,
roughly one for each of our actual human cells.
So we are all merely half the people we think we are.
Um,
this is a sponge among the simplest of animals.
It's just a couple of cell layers.
Sandwiching a bit of Jelly,
but it too is home to a thriving microbiome,
a community of bacteria and other microbes.
Every ENT,
even though it lives in a colony of millions,
is in fact a colony in itself.
A polar bear that walked solo through the Arctic.
Tundra is in fact completely surrounded bar headed geese fly microbes.
To the top of the Himalayas.
Sperm whales,
dive them down into the deepest oceans and when these people set foot on the
moon,
they were also taking a giant step for microbe kind.
These little organisms are not just stowaways,
they're not just hitchhikers and our bodies,
they also confer incredible abilities to their hosts.
This adorable creature is the Hawaiian bobtail squid.
It could fit in the palm of my hand.
It has glowing bacteria in its undersides that shine light below the squid and
that like perfectly matches the moonlight welling down on top of the animal so
that any Predator looking at the squid from below cannot make out its
silhouette.
This squared has an invisibility cloak created by bacteria light more
sinisterly.
These little white worms kill insects by vomiting toxic bacteria into their
bodies.
This bird,
the hippo paints its eggs in antibiotic producing bacteria that stopped the
chicks within the eggs from catching disease.
The spotted Hyena writes an autobiography in bacterial pastes.
It has microbes in scent glands in its backside.
Those product produce odors that match the hyenas sex age,
species,
and social status.
And this long worm called Perico 10 Ula.
A flatworm can regenerate almost its entire body as long as it has some of those
dark colored microbes within it.
Humans to rely on our microbiome for all sorts of things.
They help us to digest our food.
They help to build and shape our organs.
They helped to train and calibrate our immune systems.
They might even help to cha affect our behavior.
So I've been writing about this topic for about 10 years and there are a few
areas of biology that fascinate me more because it totally subverts our
understanding of the life around us.
I have been fascinated by natural history since I was a kid.
Um,
I went to zoos a lot.
This is a picture of me with a kid on my back.
Um,
and I watched David Attenborough documentaries and I read wildlife books and I
came to realize through writing this book and through Reese port reporting on
this topic,
that when I go to a zoo,
every visitor and resident,
there is a zoo in their own right.
When I look at the world around me at all the animals and plants,
I see all of that is profoundly influenced by things I cannot see.
And that without knowing them,
without understanding the microbes around us,
we cannot really understand ourselves and indeed without,
when we look at the microbial world,
very familiar and everyday parts of our lives take on this unfamiliar and newly
wondrous,
uh,
quality.
So for example,
breastfeeding seems like a way of nourishing a baby and it is,
but not entirely.
So,
because some 10% of breast milk consist of these sugars called human milk
oligosaccharides or just hrms,
which babies cannot digest.
Those sugars are there to nourish microbes in the baby's gut and particularly
strains like that one at the bottom be infantis,
which has evolved to specifically digest those sugars with incredible
efficiency.
And when it does that in nourishes the baby's gut cells,
it seals up the lining of the gut and it reduces inflammation.
So a breastfeeding mother is not just nourishing infants,
but in fantasy too.
She is building an entire world inside her baby's body.
She is creating an ecosystem and that ecosystem helps to create us in turn,
so every animal,
whether a hawk or a hummingbird or a human develops from a single fertilized egg
into a full adult body,
and that process doesn't just unfold under our own steam,
under instructions encoded within our own genes.
It also depends on conversations and negotiations with the microbes that live
within us.
Here is an example of an animal that utterly depends on microbes to complete its
life cycle.
These little tubes are very tiny,
but they can get so dense that they clog the propellers of ships and underwater
surfaces.
They're created by a small marine worm.
That one can only make the tubes if it becomes an adult and it can only become
an adult if it encounters the right bacteria in its environment.
If for some reason all the microbes in the ocean were to suddenly disappear,
this one would be all of these ones would die within a generation.
They would never be able to complete their lives.
More familiar creatures like mice or fish or humans or flies.
Also rely on microbes throughout their entire lives to build and shape their
bodies.
And we know this because of rodents like this one that I am sort of holding.
This is a germ free mouse.
It has been raised in this sterile plastic bubble for its entire life.
And it has one of the few creatures in the world that has no microbiome of its
own.
It does not contain multitudes.
It is like a silhouette that hasn't been filled in.
And because of that,
it's body has all kinds of problems.
It's bones don't develop properly.
It's blood vessels,
it's gut,
it's brain.
All of these things are improperly formed because it lacks that connection to
the microbial world.
Okay?
So microbes shape and sculpt our bodies,
but they also help to keep those bodies safe and healthy.
Um,
the immune system we traditionally think of as this militaristic force that
defends us against the microbial world,
that census,
anything that is other or nonself and that six and destroys it.
But that metaphor is,
is very wrong because we know that actually microbes help to build parts of the
immune system.
They stimulate the growth of different types of immune cells and they calibrate
the immune system so that it reacts to infectious threats and keeps us healthy.
But it also doesn't overreact to harmless things in the world.
US roundness to dust and pollen and allergens and our food.
Um,
and it turns out that the immune system doesn't just indiscriminately kill
microbes.
It actually tolerated the ones that live in our bodies and help us.
Um,
it selects for them.
It decides which species get to live with us and where they get to live.
So forget the militaristic analogies I like to think of.
The immune system is more as a set of ranges in a national park that are trying
to care for the species in the park,
but decide what their population size should be that chuck out invaders.
And finally,
microbes also shape our behavior.
There've been many studies in mice in some of those germ free rodents I showed
you before,
showing that the microbes that live in our can affect the way we think.
They're our resilience to stress,
our susceptibility to anxiety,
aspects of our mood and our personality.
Whether that applies to humans or not is still being checked out,
but it's entirely plausible,
almost probable because all of these aspects of our lives,
all of these corners of our biology that we think of as the province of
individuals,
digestion,
development,
immunity,
health,
thought.
All of these things happen in conversation.
They happen in partnerships with the things that share our lives and over an
individual lifespan.
Those partnerships certainly matter,
but they also matter over much longer timescales,
over evolutionary time spans time and again,
we have seen that microbes can influence the evolutionary potential of different
animal groups,
allowing them to take up opportunities that would be otherwise denied to them to
succeed in lifestyles that they would otherwise fail at.
These are good examples.
These three insects,
aphids,
Cicada,
leafhopper are all part of a group of SAP sucking bugs that drink the fluids
from plants.
And they can only do that because they have bacteria living inside their cells
that provide them with nutrients that are missing from that diet of plants,
apps that act as living dietary supplements.
Without those microbes,
these insects would be totally unable to eat the foods that they eat because it
will be too impoverished for them.
They would all die.
And these groups,
this group of insects is radiated,
uh,
to some 85,000 species.
An extraordinary example of success or founded on that bacterial assistance in
the deep oceans that are other animals that take that concept to an even greater
degree.
These are giant tube worms similar to the ones I showed you before,
but meters in length.
And with these beautiful red gills that look like a tube of lipstick that's been
pushed out or the way they live in areas in parts of the world,
like hydrothermal vents where there is no food or at least meager amount of it.
And yet they flourish in huge numbers and they do that because they have
bacteria in their bodies that use minerals from the vent environment,
break them down and use them to make any news and to make food for the worms.
Those bacteria provide this animal with all of its sustenance to the extent that
it has lost its mouth.
It's gut.
It's entire digestive system.
This thing doesn't need to eat because it has bacteria to provide it with all
the energy it has.
It needs most animals have kept their guts is a good example is he's a
Willdabeast in the African Savanna.
They like other grazing mammals like cows.
Sheep,
goats rely on microbes to break down the complex carbohydrates in the plants,
or they eat substances that they lack the ability to digest on their own,
the bacteria in their bodies,
which how in their guts,
which have been enlarged into these gigantic fermentation chambers,
and those microbes provide them with something like 70% of their energy budget.
Again,
if you somehow destroyed all the microbes in the world,
all of these Hodes would just die.
Okay,
so microbes provide animals with incredible evolutionary opportunities and they
allow them to succeed at things that they would otherwise be unable to cope
with.
They also accelerate the pace of animal evolution.
So if an animal finds a challenge,
it's an in its environment.
The traditional way of dealing with that is to adapt very slowly to accumulate
small changes in its genome and to become good more and more suited to its
environment.
But you can do that very quickly by recruiting microbes that already have those
adaptations that have already met those challenges themselves.
It's a bit like having a skills gap in an organization and rather than training
your existing employees to have those skills,
you just recruit people that already know how to do the job.
This Japanese been bug does that.
It's a major passed in Japan and it's controlled with insecticides,
but it can become instantly resistant to insecticides.
If it swallows the right bacteria in the soil which detoxify those chemicals,
this desert would rat,
can do the same.
It can eat the most common plant in it's desert environment.
If it's all those microbes that can break down the heavy poisons within that
plant.
And these aphids can become resistant to parasitic wasps that would otherwise
lay eggs in their bodies and take over.
Uh,
and they can do that by pop,
by,
uh,
taking up a beneficial microbe from their peers via sex,
which makes this one of the rare cases of a desirable venereal infection.
Humans can benefit from the sorts of transfers to this is a type of seaweed that
has been harvested from Japan for hundreds of years and used is used to make
Nori the stuff that wraps your Sushi,
uh,
nor is now cooked,
but it used to be eaten raw.
And because it used to be it in rural people who swallowed it also swallowed
marine microbes that lived on the seaweed.
And we're exceptionally good at breaking down the unique blends of nutrients and
carbohydrates within.
When those marine microbes entered the guts of people hundreds of years ago,
they met gut microbes and they did a thing that bacteria do all the time.
But that is extraordinary to us.
They swapped genes.
So you and I can only try,
it's pass our genetic material down from parent to child.
But bacteria can do this between individuals horizontally rather than
vertically.
They can cite it a lot to each other and exchange DNA as easily as you or I
might exchange phone numbers or gifts or ideas.
And that's what they did.
So the marine microbe passed on genes were breaking down carbohydrates to the
gut microbes and those passed down from person to person,
which is why to the state Japanese people have got microbiomes that are uniquely
qualified to digest the carbohydrates found in Sushi.
Okay,
so,
uh,
microbes are cool.
Microbes are important.
Um,
I hope I've convinced you of that.
Now,
one important thing I need to say is that microbes are not our friends.
Even the one that even the ones that live within us and that have beneficial
sides to them are not necessarily our allies.
And there is the story about friendly bacteria and good microbes that runs
counter to the idea of microbes,
germs,
and his villains.
But I think both of these ideas are equally wrong.
In fact,
we are just another habitat to them,
just like soil or water.
We are just another ecosystem in which they live and while we do benefit from
their presence,
those relationships like any in nature can be tenuous.
So the microbes that live in our gut,
for example,
help to break down our food,
help to train our immune system,
so on.
But if they cross the lining of the gut and enter our blood stream,
they can cause inflammation and sepsis.
They can cause disease for the want of a millimeter.
Our allies can turn into our enemies.
And so there is no such thing as a good microbe or a bad microbe.
In fact to these relationships take work.
We need ways of containing our multitudes.
We have physical barriers to keep them in specific places,
to keep them from crossing the lining of the gut.
For example,
we have the immune system to keep them in line.
We feed them with the right foods so that we nourish species that are going to
be useful to us,
like those sugars in breastmilk nourish be and Vantis.
And when those control measures breakdown as they often do,
our relationships with the microbes that live within us can turn sour.
You can see some of those dynamics at work in coral reefs.
So corals are look like bits of rock,
but they are in fact animals too.
And they also have thriving microbiomes and many of the things that kill corals
around.
Um,
so corals also have competitors things called turf algae,
this kind of scummy seaweed stuff that competes with them for space to coral
versus [inaudible].
A lot of the things that kill corals tip the balance of that war,
giving the Alga and advantage.
And when they start overgrowing they release dissolved sugars into the water,
essentially junk food and that nourishes microbes are live on the corals
allowing species that are more likely to cause disease to bloom in large
numbers.
So the algae effective return,
the corals microbiome against them.
And this is a very different view of disease than we're used to.
It's not something like tuberculosis,
which has caused by one bacterium or play,
which is caused by one bacterium.
This is a case where entire community of microbes has shifted from a normal
healthy state into one that is likely to cause disease and there's a term for
that.
It's called dysbiosis.
It's an imbalance in the microbial communities that live within us as term is
relevant to human health too because a ridiculous list of the human disorders
and diseases have been linked to changes in the microbiome a list so long that
it invites parody.
Now for most of these conditions it is still unclear if changes in the
microbiome lead to disease.
If it is the other way round,
if it is a consequence of that,
if it is both or neither and yet those links remain and so there are experiments
which suggests that there is a sort of causal effect and those have all those
involve the germ free mice that I showed you before.
There have been many studies where you take a rodent that has some problems,
say a obesity,
diabetes,
heart disease,
colorectal cancer,
you take their gut microbiomes and you put them into one of these animals and
often some of those symptoms of those conditions move across as well.
So if you load that mouse with the microbiome from an obese mouse,
it will start to put on weight.
Now would that suggests that the microbes are to an extent,
grabbing the wheel rather than just going along for the ride.
What that means for human health,
the extent to which microbes influence all these conditions that affect us and
many of which have become more common in the last half century that is still
being worked out.
Scientists are also trying to look at what's changing our microbiome,
what affects the communities that live within us and how that might affect our
health.
And there are many possible things that do that.
So humans have moved away from muddy countrysides and soil in contact with
animals and lived.
We live in these urban jungles and are more style.
We have waged a very successful war against the microbial world and have taken
the sound principles of hygiene perhaps to an excerpt degree where we sterilize
absolutely everything and have antibacterial or at all sorts of antibacterial
goods.
We use antibiotics.
These drugs have done a tremendous amount of good for us.
They have saved countless lives for infectious diseases,
but they are also unsubtle weapons.
They kill the bacteria that we depend upon as well as the ones that causes harm.
And we use them to an absurd degree,
not just when we need them,
but when we don't.
And for conditions like viral diseases for which antibiotics are completely ill
suited to.
And finally our food has changed.
We are eat,
we're eating much less plant foods,
much lower amounts of fiber.
Fiber is important because it nourishes are wide range of microbes within us.
Fiber consists of a large number of complex carbohydrates and no single species
of microbes has the cutlery set.
It needs to eat all of them.
So you eat fiber,
you nourish a very diverse community.
Okay,
so what can we do about any of this?
If anything,
if we are disconnecting ourselves from the microbial world and if those changes
are,
as some scientists suggest leading to disease,
what can we do about that?
Well,
theoretically a lot,
as I've shown you,
microbiomes can change in positive ways very quickly.
They can also change in negative ways very quickly,
which means that they should be able to change in deliberate ways that we
choose.
Unlike say our genomes,
which are the same throughout our entire lives and which required very complex
techniques in order to manipulate the microbiome is supposedly more flexible,
more mutable,
at least it is in theory,
in practice changing the world inside us is very complex.
To take something like probiotics.
These are products like yogurt sachets,
capsules,
what have you,
that supposedly contained beneficial microbes,
but even though they are very good for certain things like infectious diarrhea,
they are also medically underwhelming for a lot of other things.
They have a lot of health claims that have been linked to them and by the large
they don't meet up.
They don't meet the expectations that have been latched onto them and that's
probably because they consist of strains and species that have been chosen for
historical reasons because they're easy to manufacture and grow and package not
because they are the a listers of the gut that are good at colonizing our
bodies.
Those species of them present in very small amounts.
They are sometimes heavily industrialized,
so they've been grown in industrialized cultures where a long period of time and
are essentially domesticated microbes.
So you swallow these products,
they go in,
they don't do very much and they leave again.
They certainly don't establish themselves in your body.
I compare them to a breeze that blows between two open windows and that maybe
rattle some objects along the way,
but that doesn't have any lasting impact perhaps then it makes more sense to
give people large communities of microbes that are well suited to life in the
gut.
And that is certainly the principle behind a very unorthodox and a little
disturbing.
Uh,
her treatment call to the fecal transplant,
which is exactly what it sounds like.
Um,
it is very difficult to find an acceptable photo of a fecal transplant.
So I've prepared this very technical slide to show you how it works.
So you have a sick person and you give them store from a healthy person and then
they're better.
It's a bit like an ecosystem transplant.
I compare it to say Rita thing alone,
that's been overrun with dandelions creating this bloke lovely green fresh
pasture.
Um,
and it works at least for one specific condition called clostridium difficile,
a very weedy and invasive bacterium that can cause severe and intractable and
often fatal or cases of diarrhea.
Um,
see def,
uh,
there's been a trial or fecal transplantation force,
clostridium difficile,
uh,
in that trial,
people with the condition who were given standard antibiotics,
some 27% of them were cured,
whereas fecal transplants cured 94% of the people who took them.
And time and again,
in many studies,
this really weird and very gross procedure has worked wonders for this
particular thing.
Now,
it has therefore been tried on a lot of other conditions that the microbiome has
been implicated in inflammatory bowel disease or irritable bowel syndrome,
that sort of thing.
And they're the re the results are more inconsistent and less,
uh,
a bit less promising.
And that's probably because c diff is a very unusual situation.
It really is a bit like a monoculture of weeds.
Um,
it may be a ecosystem that is easier to reset,
whereas something like the gut of someone with inflammatory bowel disease may be
much more complicated.
And the truth is we just don't know.
We still don't really fully understand why these transplants work.
Uh,
and that's big,
that's abundantly clear when scientists tried to duplicate them.
So several companies have tried to create,
um,
essentially fecal trends of fake fecal transplant capsules that contain the
bacteria that are meant to path that the meant to be beneficial,
but without the it factor of actual feces.
Uh,
and the most promising one of these pills,
uh,
went into phase two clinical trials recently and performed really badly.
They flunked out.
Uh,
which is a big shame,
but it did allow me to write probably my best headline of the last year.
I think all of this goes to show that it is very hard to change the ecosystems
that live within us.
It is not a simple case of say,
finding someone with a vitamin deficiency,
giving them some support,
some supplements,
or like an orange and have them be better.
These are complex worlds.
They are the equivalent of jungles are coral reefs or grasslands.
And changing them is as hard as it sounds.
Um,
and we are still at the very early stages of understanding the microbiome and
how it affects our health.
We still don't know,
for example,
the full list of bacteria and other microbes that live within us.
We don't understand why the microbiome change varies from person to person.
It's certainly does,
all of our microbiomes are different to each other.
But,
um,
if you take into account dire to medicines,
all the various things that scientists think affect this world,
we can only explain maybe about 10% of the variation across the population.
The rest is a mystery.
This,
uh,
this world is also a very dynamic one.
It changes with our,
with every one of our meals with um,
the,
the rise and fall of the sun,
uh,
with our,
with the diseases and the illnesses we get and the medicines we take to make
ourselves better.
So we're still at this very early stage.
Um,
and if we look at the wider world and backtrack a bit,
so we are at this very early stage,
but in terms of using the microbiome for medical purposes,
I think there are a couple of things that we might be able to win at more
quickly than things then actually trying to change the consortium of species
that live within us.
And one might be to use the microbiome to,
um,
to target our drugs and our medicines more effectively.
So many types of medications from digoxin or heart drove to the latest
blockbuster cancer therapies to everyday things like paracetamol work better in
some people than in others depending on the microbes that they carry for various
reasons.
In some cases the bacteria break down the drugs.
In some cases they turn the drugs into some other chemicals that have toxic side
effects.
But we might be able to in the future to look at someone's microbiome and think,
okay,
you should get this drug,
it will work in you.
You should not get this one.
It's going to make you even worse.
Another thing we might be able to do is actually drug the microbiome to actually
change the way the bacteria inside his work without killing them,
without resorting to antibiotics.
So here's one particular example,
Coleen and carnitine and nutrients that are found in food that we eat and when
we eat them,
they get transformed into this,
into TMA and Tmao.
Tmao is bad news because it slows the breakdown of cholesterol and in our bodies
and increases the deposit deposition of fat in our arteries leading to heart
disease.
Okay,
what can we do about this?
Well,
we could target a,
an enzyme that we make ourselves that's encoded within our own genome,
that code that,
uh,
that is responsible for that conversion from Tma Tmao.
Uh,
there are actually drugs that can do that and that can shut down that part of
the pathway,
which is great news except TMA smells of rotting fish so it's not really
something you want building up in your body.
So let's forget about that.
That's we can try and target that bit the conversion from Coleen to TMA in the
first place and that is done by bacterial enzymes rather than human ones.
And there are drugs like one called DMV that can knock those enzymes out and
therefore shut that pathway down.
Now you'll probably have heard of statens statens are drugs that are given to
people who have high cholesterol.
We have a high risk of heart disease and statens work by targeting the human bit
of us.
Maybe in the future you go to a doctor with a and you have high cholesterol,
you have a high risk of heart disease.
Your doctor prescribes you to drugs a Staten to control the human bit of you and
something like Dmv to control the bacterial better view.
Okay.
As I've tried to say,
all of this is still in a very early stage.
We are only beginning our exploration of the microbial world,
even though it's been 350 years since leaving hope first saw those little
organisms under his incredibly powerful lenses.
If we go into the wider world,
our ignorance becomes clearer and there are apps even more daunting.
This picture is a tree of life.
This represents everything that exists.
It is a master family tree of life on earth.
Now,
if I zoom in to this bit here,
that's you.
Uh,
this tiny little twig on this glow green feather are all the animals and plants
are all the humans.
All the things that you are familiar with.
The rest of this tree is microbial.
And if you look at the red dots that are everywhere,
those represent groups that have never been seen and never been isolated.
We only know that they exist because someone has sequenced their DNA from some
bits of the world around us,
from soil,
from water,
from our own bodies.
And that purple spray on the right that was discovered,
I think a few months ago,
possibly know more than a year.
That is a vast amount of bacterial diversity.
Most of which was found in a single river in Colorado.
So think about how much we still have yet to discover about the world around us
as microbiologists.
Jonathan Eisen,
right?
We basically know nothing about the total diversity of the tree of life.
And I think that this diversity is worth exploring.
We can't see these things.
We don't know what they are.
They seem insignificant to us.
And yet the exploration of the microbial world can lead to massive and
unexpected benefits for us.
And that is the theme of the final story that I am going to tell you.
It involves this guy,
a scientist called simion Burt wall back in 1924 he and a colleague named
Marshall Hertig discovered a new type of bacterium inside the cells of an insect
and they didn't know what it was.
They didn't know whether it was common,
what it did.
It took them 12 years for hurting to actually give the thing a name.
And he named it after his friend and called it war back here or back here.
Lives in the cells of insects and it lives in the cells of a lot of insects.
A decade after these two found it,
loads of scientists who were studying bacteria in intake probably suddenly
realized that they were all studying the same thing,
which was this thing.
This is found in something like 40% of species of insects and other arthropods,
and given that those are already the most diverse and rich and abundant
organisms on the planet,
this is almost certainly one of the most successful bacteria in the world.
And what it does varies from host host.
Well back here is a bit of a misaddressed.
It doesn't like males because it only passes down the female line from mother to
daughter.
Sons are a dead end to it,
and it deals with that in many different ways.
In this animal,
the Blue Moon Butterfly,
it just kills male embryos outright so that some populations have a hundred
females to every one male,
uh,
in some wood lice wall back here transforms males into females in some wasps.
It allows the females to reproduce by cloning themselves asexually so that they
have no need for males at all in other insects.
Well back here is some people are smiling on their own.
Why can we get this?
I'm sorry we're back.
It doesn't.
In fact people there are in some cases it is an ally is beneficial in this
animal.
Them bedbug.
It provides B vitamins that are missing from the animal's blood meals.
This leaf has a little green bit and the corner.
This is the work of a caterpillar that uses wall back here to stop the leaf from
turning yellow,
creating this little green island in which the insect can continue to feed.
But the thing will back here does that is most interesting to us in vols and
insect that doesn't naturally curry it nuts.
This the tiger mosquito eighties a tie,
this thing spreads yellow fever,
dengue fever,
Zika,
Chikungunya,
all kinds of nasty tropical diseases.
And for 25 years Australian scientists have been trying to put wall back here.
Insiders,
mosquito.
And they finally succeeded a while back and they've spent so much time doing
this because when the tiger mosquito carries wall back here,
it cannot spread the viruses that cause all those diseases I talked about.
It transforms from a vector into a dead end for human disease.
The other thing that's great about this is that wall back here is amazing.
It's spreading through populations because it changes the reproductive biology
of its host.
If you release infected mosquitoes into the wild within a few generations,
all the insects and the local area should carry this muskie to this bacterium
and thus be unable to spread the diseases that cause us harm.
And this approach has been tried in a few places.
This is an experiment in 2011 that in a suburb in Australia that went from
January to May,
these gray bars represent the release of war Bacchae infected mosquitoes in that
suburb.
And the Green Line shows the proportion of the wild insects that carry the
bacterium that went from zero to a hundred by this point,
all the insects buzzing over that suburb can't spread.
Things like danglies,
Eaker and the like.
And this approach is now being tested in larger parts of the world in places
like Brazil,
Colombia,
Indonesia,
and Vietnam in mega cities that have huge problems with these diseases.
It's got many advantages to it.
Uh,
unlike insecticides,
which need to be re sprayed constantly and which are toxic.
Well back here is not all back here,
doesn't infect humans.
It doesn't infect other animals that might eat mosquitoes.
It doesn't kill the insects.
So it doesn't have any ecological consequences.
We're not going to look at,
uh,
at,
domino effects from a world without mosquitoes.
And it doesn't involve any Jersey multiplication.
Uh,
so for people who have a problem with that and might be,
uh,
might be against using this approach,
well back here is fine.
It doesn't,
it doesn't count.
Now,
could marshal and heartache have predicted any of this?
Could they have seen in 1924 when they're discovered this thing that it might be
a solution to some of these diseases that infect,
that affect millions of people?
I highly doubt it.
In fact,
walback died in 19 in the 1950s way before anyone realized how common wall back
his way before he,
he,
before anyone realized that his name had been grafted onto one of the greatest
pandemics in the history of life and the solution to many of our health
problems.
And I think the story of Wall back here is the story of animal associated
microbes in a nutshell.
For the longest time we ignore these things,
we neglected them and then we fed them.
And now I think it is time to appreciate them because they are crucial parts of
the world around us.
They might be important for us,
not just for changing the way we live,
but the way we think about ourselves and our place in the world.
And I think all of that begins with basic curiosity.
It was that,
that drove those two people to look at that,
uh,
to find wall back here in the first place.
It was that that drove low,
even hope to look at water and see the microbial world for the first time.
And it's that sense of curiosity and wonder though.
I would like to instill in people through the book.
Thank you very much.
Sure.
I think we have to run five minutes for questions.
Great.
So I think a lot of media about gene therapy and oh,
we found a new gene that does this and what x and y and so forth.
Do you think the,
a lot of research has been placed into genes and DNA
and so forth,
where as perhaps it should have been placed into a study of bacteria and micro
bio?
Well,
I wouldn't like to,
I don't feel it's a zero sum game.
I mean it kind of is because there's funding is limited,
but like we need to understand all of these aspects of ourselves.
I think,
um,
uh,
understanding the human genome,
um,
and,
and using it to improve our health.
Um,
I think we'll,
we'll pay off in the long run.
Um,
but the,
the microbiome has been an underappreciated side of our biology and I think it's
getting it's share of the limelight now.
I think the comparison is that because,
um,
when the human genome came out about 12 years ago,
it wasn't now,
um,
they were grandiose claims made about it,
understanding,
um,
all of our DNA would give us solutions to all of these problems like
schizophrenia,
cancer or all of these things.
Um,
and that's been slow to turn up because biology is always more complicated than
we think it is.
And then 10 years on there was backlash.
People were saying,
Oh,
where is all the stuff that came out of the human genome that you promised?
I think the microbiome is going through exactly the same kind of hype cycle.
Now.
You know,
we,
I've,
I've been to conferences where people talk about the microbes within us as if
they were going to be this panacea for all of our health problems.
And I think they might explain a lot of things,
but we're still so far away from turning into an application into a practical or
even a predictive science.
I can't look at your microbiome now and tell you like,
what,
like what you have,
what you're at risk of.
Um,
we're just,
we're just not that stage yet.
Cool.
Hey,
um,
I have a bit of a tangential question.
Okay.
Uh,
so you mentioned the gut microbes in Japan doing the DNA swab thing.
How does that actually get inherited to children?
Is it through breastfeeding or similar or,
yeah,
it's a good question.
So we,
um,
we do pass on some of our microbes to our kids,
and that's probably just through social contact.
Um,
anyone who has ever watched a birth one know that it's a messy process and bits
from all sorts of organ systems end up in all sorts of places.
So yeah,
you do get,
you do get stuff passed along.
Um,
and that probably explains why it transfers that happen in one individual could
then cascade down the generations.
Okay,
thanks.
You said that,
um,
there's no,
uh,
evidence that
microbes are involved in the,
in human development.
I mean,
the classic story was that the sort of inside the placenta was sterile.
Is,
is there now much evidence to show that the are actually microbes inside?
Right.
That's a good question.
I more meant after babies are born.
So as we grow up,
um,
they help to shape the development of,
you know,
various organs,
uh,
even in a continual way.
They help too.
They effect influence,
say the regeneration of the cells that line the gut.
So it's more of a continuous process that starts off to birth,
at least for for us.
Um,
it certainly used to be thought of and still largely is thought that the womb is
a sterile environment.
There have been a few studies suggesting that I've claimed to have found signs
of bacterial DNA in the womb and then these other tissues like the amniotic sac
and the umbilical cord.
I'm doubtful of that.
Um,
I'm,
I'm very,
very skeptical about it and it,
I've asked a lot of scientists who work in this field and there are also very
skeptical,
but um,
so the,
the sterile womb paradigms still holds.
I think it's,
it might be overturned the future,
but it's not yet.
Any more questions?
Yup.
What do you use instead of shampoo?
I use shampoo.
I,
um,
I feel that the,
the thing,
okay,
the way to think about hygiene is just in terms of common sense.
You know,
I don't think any of us want to go back to a time when people were sanitation
wasn't a thing.
And we were,
you know,
having a drinking like sewage contaminated water.
Uh,
I certainly think that my friends and family would be much happier if I actually
showered a lot.
Um,
but I think we go too far with it,
you know,
so I,
um,
I'm not one to say use like hand sanitizers all the time and um,
uh,
and I think that we,
we take the concert to hygiene,
we take the concert to cleanliness like,
uh,
to,
to an absurd degree.
And I think there's kind of balance.
There is moderation to be happy.
One more question.
Thank you Brian.
So I am the conversation around over use of antibiotics.
Do you address that in the book?
Can,
do you think that conversation is him?
You said,
be gathering some momentum at the moment?
Uh,
although I recently read that they'd found a new strain and I'll knows,
Oh,
H I'm not sure how it got picked up by the popular press or I mean,
are we screwed?
Is,
are we aware of using antibiotics,
but is it competition moving in the right way to reduce that use?
Yeah,
I feel that it is.
Um,
maybe,
uh,
so,
okay.
So we are running out of antibiotics.
We have,
um,
we have discovered no new classes in several decades and the bacteria are
becoming increasingly resistant to the ones that we do have.
So yeah,
we're kind of screwed.
Um,
and we're,
we're in a,
we're in really bad shape with it.
Uh,
I'm not going to lie.
It is kind of terrifying.
Um,
in in many ways reducing the use of antibiotics has two wins attached to it.
It reduces the,
uh,
it's slows down the evolution of a drug microbes,
the ones that causes harm.
And it also spares the ones that live in our bodies and do good for us.
So it,
it's a win win thing and we should,
we should be more judicious about our use of antibiotics.
People get so many courses of treatment that they have that they really do not
need.
Um,
and even if you go beyond the human world,
um,
antibiotics in agriculture is,
uh,
is,
used incredibly heavily and that should be cut back on to a are we,
it is there hope?
Well,
sort of.
Um,
there,
there was that paper about a new antibiotic found in the nose.
Um,
we,
uh,
I actually wrote about that at the Atlantic.
The human microbiome seems like a really good potential source of new
antibiotics.
The reason why they looked in the nose is that,
um,
the mouth and the gut are places full of microbes,
but they are also full of nutrients.
We eat stuff all the time.
So we feed that the things that live there.
The nose has no resources.
So unless you're eating in a really strange way,
the bacteria in your nose have little to go on.
And so they are incredibly competitive.
They need to fight for everything that's there.
Um,
and antibiotics are bacterial weapons or the things that we use to treat
ourselves are derived from molecules that bacteria use to wage war on each
other.
So if you're looking in places in the body where microbes will probably be
experiencing the greatest amount of competition,
we might be able to more easily find new drugs,
or at least that was the reason behind looking in the nose.
Um,
but these things take,
you know,
to go from finding a new drug in a laboratory study to actually having a
marketable antibiotic takes a lot of work and one of the problems at the moment
does that.
And then there's basically no incentive for doing that.
Um,
they're like,
if you're a pharmaceutical company,
your business model is to find a new drug,
release it into the,
into the market,
have it be a cohort or blockbuster dominates the market for a few years before
your patent runs out.
So you make as much money as possible.
Problem with antibiotics is that what everyone tells you to do with antibiotics
is to hold back on them until you really need them.
So a business model where you're producing a new drug and then people tell you
not to use it for a very long time is a crap one,
which is why there's been so much disinvestment here.
So I think it's not just a case of finding new drugs or like slowing down our
use of the current ones.
We also need to change the economics of it.
And there have been suggestions of creating these like,
um,
uh,
like entry reward schemes where you pay,
you pay companies for the process of research and development,
um,
and you do that through like public funds that will probably be need,
probably need to be gathered through large international parts.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
We are running out of [inaudible] so thank you again.
[inaudible].